tea is one of the top prospects in the
2020 NFL Draft live here on the Rich
Eisen show front Clemson football Isiah
Simmons how are you guys ale
I'm good I am fine where have I found
you where are you right now that's where
you now why are you in there why are you
there right now so you that's where you
from you're from there how did you wind
up at Clemson Isiah Simmons yeah so
Clemson came super late they came about
a month before hunting day and the
reason I came about was game on cards
because I was an see they're green they
all declared for the national
championship our after the national
championship 2015 so coach has his wife
is from this area is history I can't
state so he had burned around here and
we got my film sent to him and he said
he loved it immediately you know you
know history so that's how he found you
in the middle of this country right
there in Kansas and that's how you wound
up a Clemson Tiger it's basically right
because his wife had ties to the area
isn't that amazing how that works
sometimes
who else was knocking on your door at
the time Oh
Michigan a lot of Big Ten schools a lot
of they 12 cores
okay let me linger on that you know
where I went to school I was at Simmons
you know where I went to school I went
to the University of Michigan why didn't
you choose that institution of higher
learning and excellence why don't you go
there what have I been at Clemson before
I don't have to go to Clemson to know
Michigan's the all-time greatest spot on
planet Earth Isaiah you know all know
Dabo is also pretty damn convincing when
wants to be a bet right yeah so what's
your relationship what was your
relationship with him like cuz I'm sure
and I heard that's why I'm saying I'm
sure you wanted to play offense Isiah
right you wanted to get some snaps on
the offensive side of the ball correct
yeah a couple a lot of games where you
know we were out pretty big and I my
coaches let me get one goal ball and
just let the quarterback let it ride and
you know he he wasn't really going well
he was just laughs and you know kinda
giggle but you know he plays a lot of
player these games so I'm like maybe
I'll get a shot but then they told me if
I get a picnic that I'll get my chance
so I got one and I didn't get my chance
that year so this path
if we get a bag on Ohio season how let
you get one
I'm kidding it was because he just
didn't want me to go out there and get
you say what would that look like if you
go get injured in the fourth quarter and
we're up by 40 points so I mean it was
all out the goodness of his heart but I
know a lot more so how good of a
receiver can you be yeah I know you did
it in high school but you know Clemson
as we all know is maybe why drew you
right now what we're seeing perform in
the NFL how good can you be at that
position high school I had twenty nine
receptions for nine hundred ninety four
yards and seven touchdowns so I mean and
then interestingly enough there is a
debate a raging debate actually amongst
NFL scouts and NFL evaluators as to
what's the best position for you in the
NFL what is the best position for you in
the NFL isaiah simmons you call it what
do you what what are you what do you
make of that now that they have that i
could play a similar role that clemson
on you see it happen out with Tyra
Matthews and Aaron James still play a
similar role and expect the game from
everywhere just like I well that's just
like I did in college that's a smart
answer see you could have gone to
Michigan that's such a smart answer you
could have been a missionary I mean cuz
you're not gonna peg yourself right
there but where are you most comfortable
then which level are you most
comfortable in Isaiah I don't I don't
really believe that there's a level that
I'm more comfortable and then another
because I'm I'm just as comfortable
rushing the passer as I am out in
coverage so the pasta me to dive into
one Isiah Simmons here in the Rich Eisen
show a few more minutes left with Asya
who's here courtesy of Old Spice which
we'll get to in a second how many teams
have you been chatting with okay so
Giants you chatted with the Giants
part of the captain okay you chatted
with the Browns if you chatter with the
Browns
I said briefly um dolphins you chatter
with the dolphins have you chatted with
the Patriots Isaiah Simmons you tell me
yes or no have you chatted with the New
England haters
I have not actually yes my just my at
the combine Oh at the combine okay did
you did you chat with Bill Belichick
himself at the combine question in there
so Bill Belichick was in the room when
you were they run all right what he did
what he asked you what are you asking
can you remember
see he is smart yeah that's like Fight
Club you can't talk about Bella check
you're right I don't want to get you in
trouble I don't want to ruin your dress
stock but your draft stock is not ruin a
bull quite frankly I mean you are as on
fire as anybody is right now if I told
you that when you were growing up in
Kansas what would you said I like it
okay yeah so you're you're striking a
blow for all of football in the state of
Kansas that's right I'm trying to help
sometimes out the guys you know I'm
trying to just pay you the way a little
bit so everything will be easier to do
you know I'm just I'm just bringing my
cell my flower along to help a little
walk Jordy Nelson right can't forget
Jordi Jordi to the Kansas State right
let's not forget him and now then I'm
sure forgetting many others and now you
Isaiah Simmons okay so Old Spice is
gonna start donating a bunch of money on
behalf of you and other and other
prospects correct that's what's going to
know that's right yeah to be exact three
hundred thousand dollars just to United
Way just to support other brothers
privileged cards and their families so
I'm really excited just a partner with
them just because of the great history
that they have was helping athletes as
well as how it's going to be a great
jumpstart on the impact of the new
community that I end up in and I grew I
grew up wearing Old Spice day and day
out for grandfather wore kind of all I
really knew so being able now you know
like my dream coming true of being
drafted and then getting this partner
with something I grew up with feels
really cool and also it's a good thing
that popped in mind all that's great I'm
happy for you Isaiah Simmons um you know
of so many Giants fans watch you play
against Ohio State and we're texting me
saying that's our that's my guy that
wouldn't that's my guy that's what they
were all saying I know you don't want to
peg yourself but New York City that's
not a bad spot new jersey new york city
right you gotta be used to the cold
I mean Kansas is not the warmest spot
all the time so you got to be just fine
with that right look you know I'm from
that area if you do wind up in that area
on Thursday night you know how to reach
me and plus I don't know if you're aware
but you know I'm I've been with NFL
Network since 2003 when you were way
before your Old Spice wearing days so
when you enter the National Football
League and my show calls the Rich Eisen
show calls you have to eat it's your
mentor it's a mandatory that you that
you appear on the show I don't know if
you're aware of that that is not an
acceptable answer we'll see about that
one the answer is okay rich come on no
you don't know what you don't know I
guess is missing bring it on full circle
I'll just take that as a yes that's the
way I'll take it and
we'll chop down the road good luck to
you have a great draft night hope it's
as quick as you want it to be thank you
right back at you that is Isaiah Simmons
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here